wie es israel geht kann man stets ein
bisschen habe strand von tel aviv
ablesen noch ist es leerer als sonst in
der partystadt aber die stimmung ist
trotz lauter und optimistischer
die impfkampagne rollt im märz soll das
land durch geimpft sein
und wer schon die zweite dosis erhalten
hat soll einen grünen pass mit
privilegien zu kommen super idee
verpasst sobald auch die jüngeren
geimpft werden mache ich es sofort damit
ich ohne test und quarantäne ins ausland
fahren kann
noch aber ringen menschen im ganzen land
mit dem corona virus sowie natalia
slawski früher hatte die oberschwester
im medical center von carson alle arten
von kranken zu versorgen jetzt zeigen
die patienten auf ihrer station nur noch
ein krankheitsbild krone was das mit der
macht kann man in ihren händen lesen
seht ihr das an das in corona hände
hände die schon lange gegen korona
kämpfen alles stellt sich wegen der
desinfektionsmittel
die hygiene zwängt natalie jeden tag in
die total vermummung macht aus ihr ein
anonymes wesen natalies foto wie aus
einer anderen zeit soll dem patienten
wenigstens ein bisschen persönliche nähe
vermitteln
und doch hat sie zu jedem einzelnen eine
eigene beziehung jeder todesfall auf
ihrer corona station trifft sie aufs
neue
psychologisch ist es schwer zuletzt
starben viele jüngere 60 70 jährige die
noch jahrzehnte hätten leben können sie
kamen auf ihren eigenen beinen reihen
und wurden im sack rausgetragen
das war sehr schwer für mich doch heute
endet ihr tag mit einem
hoffnungsschimmer
als eine der ersten bekommt sie die
zweite corona impfdosis das ende des
alptraums ist greifbar geworden ich bin
glücklich ich hoffe wir kommen so
schnell wie möglich raus aus corona zu
einem normalen leben zu patienten die
uns wieder sehen können
diese die hoffnung auf den button b
impfung die nation antreibt kann man an
dieser einrichtung in halver sehen 1 ins
tor
israel will mit aller macht die wände in
der korona krise selbst auch alles was
tempo macht mehr als 2000 personen am
tag können hier geimpft werden und zwar
sehr sicher in ihrem auto so dass sie
außerhalb nicht auf andere menschen
treffen und so hat das land in gut drei
wochen das unglaubliche geschafft an die
zwei millionen menschen haben bereits
mindestens eine impfdosis erhalten das
sind über 20 prozent der bevölkerung
dass dieser kraftakt gelingen kann hat
einen grund es gibt nur vier
krankenkassen durch die haben große
kompetenzen
sie verfügen über eigene
gesundheitszentren und mobile teams auch
die alten und pflegeheimes wurden
durchgeimpft die impfkampagne wird
zentral gesteuert und von staat und
armee unterstützt zusätzlich laufen auf
allen kanälen spots die aufklären und
für die impfung werben
unsere kassen sind sehr geübt in diesen
dingen wenn so eine infektion auf sie
zukommt können sie schnell personal
einstellen
das ausbilden und die logistik leiten um
die bürger zu erreichen
die wiederum verlassen sich auf sie und
machen mit dennoch treiben den corona
beauftragten große sorgen um denn was er
auf seinen täglichen reisen durchs land
zu sehen bekommt ist ein anderes bild
des im weltmeisters in haifa hat das
krankenhaus rambam seine tiefgarage zur
corona station ausgebaut intensivbetten
in parkbuchten
gedacht war das mal für den echten krieg
nicht für den gegen ein virus durch die
korona betten werden knapp noch wirkt
die impfkampagne kaum
erst gestern wurden neun 1600 neue
infektionen an einem tag gemeldet so
viele wie noch nie
die größte herausforderung ist dass wir
jetzt in einer zeit kommen in der die
infektionsrate zunimmt und unser
gesamtes gesundheitssystem stark
ausgelastet ist in den gemeinden und in
den krankenhäusern sowie hier
dabei ist das land seit fast vier
monaten im dauerlauf daun nach kleinen
lockerungen steht israel inzwischen
wieder komplett still
ohne durchschlagenden erfolg das problem
bestimmte minderheiten die arabische
israelis oder ultraorthodoxe halten die
regeln nicht ein wie auf dieser hochzeit
in bata illic eine große menschenmenge
in einem gebäude kaum masken keinen
abstand das entscheidende die polizei
erscheint greift aber nicht ein
erst später wird die versammlung
aufgelöst die polizisten hinterher
suspendiert auch bei der impfquote
liegen ultra orthodoxe gemeinden in
israel deutlich unter dem durchschnitt
obwohl viele rabbis anweisung gegeben
haben sich impfen zu lassen
yehuda risiko wird lebt und hat sich
bereits impfen lassen
auch er glaubt wie viele ultraorthodoxe
dass gott und sein rabbi über dem gesetz
stehen
bei impfungen sieht er aber keinen
konflikt auch in der orthodoxen
gesellschaft gibt es natürlich
verschiedene strömungen verschiedene
rabbiner der mainstream bekommt seine
anweisungen aber von rabbi kaniewski und
tut was er sagt gibt es gruppen die sich
nicht impfen lassen
da gibt es aber das sind randgruppen um
die impfungen noch attraktiver zu machen
plant die regierung allen zweifach
geimpften besagten grünen pass
auszustellen
die inhaber dürfen theater kinos und
restaurants besuchen und reisen ohne
anschließende quarantäne in deutschland
wohl ein fall für
verschwörungstheoretiker in israel
ich will den grünen pass haben ich habe
gehört man krieg denn mit impfung
ich liebe israel ich würde mich aber
auch freuen hier mal rauszukommen
auch schwester nathalie hofft dass ihr
leben nun bald ein anderes wird in einer
woche wenn ich immun bin muss ich nicht
mehr in quarantäne
ich hoffe dass wir dann langsam alle zu
einem normalen leben zurückkehren
die chancen dafür stehen mitglieder